je vous montre un truc complètement fait
avant que vous parlez du casque en
détail regardez la vie de ma chambre
on a loupé ailleurs state building qui
est juste en face je vous emmène
aujourd'hui on est à new york on high
times square pour parler casque à
l'adduction bruit je me suis dit que
pour parler d'addiction louis rien de
tel qu'un endroit où il y avait beaucoup
de bruit mais en toute chose je vais
plutôt vous ramener à ce matin à genève
on va prendre les choses dans l'ordre
on est aujourd'hui à genève j'ai un
avion dans à peu près quelque chose
comme deux heures un peu moins de deux
heures des actions euro
new york direction new york ensuite en
quelques jours dans trois quatre jours
la direction las vegas pour aller au cs
comme l'année dernière voire de toutes
les nouveautés tac qui est mon avis car
ces trucs hyper dingue je pense qu'on va
se marrer en plus j'écris plein de
soirée dans plainte recrache vous en dit
pas plus je garde le suspense homme qui
peut durer quelques jours aujourd'hui et
j'en profite du trajet pour tester un
produit que j'ai eu et pas longtemps que
le père noël m'emmener merci père noël
c'est le nouveau casque sony c'est le
cas ce que nos imprononçable enfin tu
recopies qui a retenu en tout cas le w h
he will x n 3 qui juste une petite bombe
atomique alors je veux pas vous le
cacher ça fait quelques jours que je lai
que j'utilise me ferait plaisir avec fut
testée dans le train gdc dans le budget
et c'est dans plein de cases différent
et il est juste ouf
alors là en fait il est pas du tout
allumer donc voilà mais en termes de
réduction de bruit
il est complètement hallucinant il ya
des choses que j'aime les choses que
j'aime un peu moins par contre j'ai
vraiment très très curieux de tester
c'est dans l'avion parce que il est
vraiment fait pour l'avion par pas que
pour l'avion s'est dirigé au but pour
l'avion il y aura un problème se produit
la nôtre qui est vraiment optimisé quand
on va prendre l'avion parce qu'en
fonction de l'altitude
il va falloir re calibrer regret vous
pouvez régler en tout cas par rapport à
la pression atmosphérique donc le truc
est vraiment franchement hyper hyper ouf
on va acheter dans différents
environnements on va le tester à
l'aéroport john r on va tester
bien sûr dans l'avion par l'envol on va
les tester ensuite à new york en
attendant avant de partir regardez-moi
ça vous avez les actes suisse super beau
temps de fou ce matin c'est
mais j'adore cet endroit et j'en profite
en même temps à faire un petit coucou à
mon pote mr parié avec qui on a mangé
hier soir on s'est fait une once effet
une fondue suisse 1 le chef du mal avec
l'accent avec les gens sinon c'est une
super fond du système vraiment cool donc
voilà donc salon de soirée et maintenant
on pas à nos vieillards
[Musique]
nous
donc le relais dans l'aéroport de genève
il ya beaucoup de bruit ici forcément
déjà ça couvre un petit peu au niveau de
l'audio mais j'entends l'espèce de fond
en bout du pont en bois qui traîne
j'allume hélas élimine complètement
j'entends toujours un peu des bruits
mais c'est un peu plus lointain c'est
assez imprécis en fait pourtant un peu
de voix mais il y a plus le ronronnement
de fond là je récupère ce qui est assez
impressionnant fait c'est que ça coûte
complètement du bruit ambiant soutien
côté un peu reposante on n'est pas
obligé d'écouter la musique à fond ça
c'est intéressant
[Musique]
s
dans nos matches shocking
au curling
oh non on entend toujours un peu le sont
en fait derrière toujours un peu le son
de la voix dans toujours d un peu de
bruit mais s'avoue réduit vraiment où le
son de fond tous les espèces de 2 de
ronronnement qui sont vraiment pas
agréable et ça change vraiment
complètement l'expérience sonore c'est
beaucoup plus reposant c'est franchement
cool c'est très agréable
certains médecins souhaitent se mettre
un peu dans sa bulle et je pense on
verra on en parlera ce soir
tout à leur peau et quand on arrive à
destination on sent quand même vachement
plus reposé
[Musique]
les faillites
john
des rails
est-ce que là
[Musique]
magazine
s'il ya bien un endroit qui est juste
toi pour tester un casque à réduction de
bruit ça ici à times square
parce qu'ici il ya toujours beaucoup de
bruit toujours beaucoup de monde
toujours beaucoup de lumière et pour le
coup c'est franchement idéal alors bien
sûr ça on active
c'est l'impression j'entends peu de
bruit c'est un peu médium mais ça me
coûte tout le bruit de fond ça ne couvre
tout le monde
j'ai plus du tout et c'est vrai
j'entends un peu et je me sens d'être
dans ma bulle
alors je sois prêt times square alors
que ces événements de tous les côtés
alors que je sais qu'il ya un bruit de
fou ça ne coûte vraiment le bon à de la
bible et ça franchement c'est génial et
je vais vous montrer un truc
complètement ouf avant que vous parlez
du casque en détail regardez la vie de
ma chambre
on a land bailleur state building qui
est juste en face c'est juste difficile
je suis au 15e étage d'une tour c'est
complètement ouf
bon ça c'était pour le point de détail
maintenant je vais vous parler du casque
pour moi un casque à rennes font
ailleurs pour moi un casque à réduction
de bruit doit répondre à trois critères
importants
le premier c'est la qualité du son est
ce que le son est bien ou pas le
deuxième c'est la qualité de la
réduction de bruit est ce que la qualité
est vraiment là est ce qui est une vraie
belle réduction de bruit ou pas et le
troisième c'est est ce que le casque
confortable ou pas est-ce que lorsque
vous le portez vous êtes bien et si vous
portez pendant longtemps
est-ce qu'il est cool alors premier
point au niveau de l'audio je trouve que
la qualité audio est franchement bien
franchement impressionnante après on
écoute du mp3 moi j'ai mes différentes
applications soit apple musique se 10h
spotify ce que vous voulez aux consorts
ou j'écoute des films la qualité est pas
optimal donc en retour je n'ai pas avoir
un truc complètement optimale néanmoins
je regrette que le spectre est
franchement bien qu'on aille sur des
graphes des baux grave pas des seules
deux sont très très grave on a vraiment
quelque chose de vraiment pas mal d
aigus très précis des médiums qui sont
vraiment beaux ita raccrocheurs sont une
vraie belle qualité audio en plus dessus
vous avez l'appli vous pouvez
complètement venir customiser vos
équaliseur vous pouvez les paramétrer
phare le réglage que vous voulez le
réglage des aigus des médiums des basses
vous avez différentes scènes en face ça
s'est vraiment bien donc déjà au niveau
de la qualité du son c'est super alors
après vous avez aussi une autre option
pour la pièce est ce que dans une pièce
plus confiné est ce qu une pièce comme
un théâtre comme un stade je vois pas
trop l'intérêt
mais c'est complètement impossible en
tout cas ne serait-ce que lorsque vous
l'écoutez comme ça flatte sa marche trés
la qualité est vraiment bien donc de ce
point de vue la qualité audio il ya
vraiment un excellent boulot c'est
là-dessus faut savoir que moi j'aime
bien les casque sony j'en avais déjà
avant je dis toujours c'est mon casque
et mon vieux studio 19h50 à 75,06 donc
bon on n'est pas du tout dans la même
chose mais ça marche vraiment bien
deuxième point c'est la réduction bruit
est ce que la réduction de bruit est ok
là dessus où ils n'ont et franchement
franchement je suis pas impressionné je
me devais essayer le marc delas le mark
iii va encore plus loin il ya une vraie
belle réduction bruit il ya encore je
pense à coussins imperfections à
corriger mais c'est au niveau des
technos havas a continué à évoluer
lorsque vous le mettez ça vous en avons
tous les ronronnements tous les to les
bouilles très graves si vous en avez
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
il reste un peu de médium je pense ça
sera peut-être que les révolutions les
évolutions tout cas dans les années à
venir de vraiment venir chercher à
complètement vous couper du son
extérieur savons déjà je dirais aller à
85 90 % mais les petits 10 15% qui reste
lorsqu'on va réussir à les éliminer ça
va être complètement dingue mais déjà la
qualité franchement en termes de
réduction de bruit elle est énorme dans
l'avion dans une voiture dans un but
dans un train ça vous coupe complètement
au final les trajets sont pas du tout
les mêmes
j'ai tapé huit heures et demie d'avion
huit heures et demie d'avion entre le
casque sur la tête sans forcément mettre
de la musique ou même l'écoutant des
films avec ça il ne serait ce qu'en
voulant se reposer en lien sur la tête
avec la réduction de bruit vous sortez
de là vous êtes vraiment beaucoup mieux
que lorsque vous êtes taper 8h30 d'avion
avec vos collègues
donc ça c'est vraiment un excellent
point il ya vraiment un très très beau
boulot fait là dessus de la part de sony
d'autant plus que vous avez d un bouton
avec plusieurs paramètres vous pouvez
faire le choix d'amplifier le son
extérieur notamment ce que vous allez
faire du jogging pour vraiment vous
alerter des bruits environnants ça c'est
important
et vous pouvez aussi complètement
désactivé
la réduction de bruit pour avoir comme
castrés normal je vois pas trop
l'intérêt
mais quand tout allait de son but pur et
dur ça marche super bien mettre un
troisième point est ce qu'il est
confortable
oui ou non alors c'est là où je pense
encore un petit peu de boulot à faire au
niveau des oreilles ça vient bien épousé
en tout cas la forme de mes oreilles ça
marche très bien d'autres sujets pas de
souci maintenant c'est au niveau de la
tête ici alors on est une mousse c'est
pourtant au toucher vraiment très
agréable mais là je sens toujours un
petit point l'envoyer au niveau de ma
tête
oh non crâne au bout d'un moment au bout
d'une heure une heure et demie alors je
me bouge un peu un peu vers l'avant ou
vers l'arrière
bon je pense qu'il ya un petit point à
améliorer là dessus mais ça c'est
vraiment du point de détail parce que je
trouve que vraiment ce casque le w h
mais l'ex n 3 est vraiment excellent
l'autonomie est complètement folle j'ai
dû bouffer 10% de batteries en utilisant
pendant huit heures et demie
complètement ouf
et il est vraiment bien donc ça de ce
point de vue là aussi c'est vraiment
très très bon alors la question est-ce
qu'il faut acheter ce casque si vous
voulez un casque à réduction de bruit en
bluetooth
franchement faut pas hésiter par contre
il est pas cadeau on est à un peu moins
de 400 euros par contre du coup vous
trouvez la deuxième version était moins
chère s'arrête un peu plus cher mais par
contre au final vous avez une vraie
belle qualité audio et ça c'est plus
important
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui pour
ce petit test indirectement new york
vous invite à rester connectés parce que
on va aller dès demain en fin de tour
directement dans new york on va les
tester du smartphone j'en dis pas plus
ce rendez-vous dès demain il en sera
fait une petite vue du land tailleur
state building décroche pas j'adore ça
je rêvais ya pas longtemps je fus en
grains qui doivent attendre le vent
regardez moi ça c'est juste magnifique
voilà on se quitte là dessus à demain
[Musique]